look I didn't want to be a half
blood being a half blood is dangerous
it's
scary most of the time it gets you
killed in painful nasty
[Music]
ways if you think you might be one of us
my advice is turn away while you still
can because once you know what you
are they'll sense it too
and they'll come for
you don't say I didn't warn
[Music]
you my name is Percy Jackson I'm 12
years
old am I a troubled
kid yeah you could say that bad grades
bully
all the normal
stuff and then there's some other
stuff some stuff that's maybe not so
normal that's me back in second
grade why was I up
there I saw
something
at
least I could have sworn I saw
[Music]
something when you say you saw something
like that you wind up in this guy's
office good news he's saying there's
nothing to worry about it's all in my
imagination but if it happens again make
sure to tell
someone it happened
again these impossible things
it felt like they walked right out of
the stories my mom always told me so
real one
minute and then the
next what a
loser hey fellas want to come hear about
the imaginary stuff I see it's not a
thing you want to be saying to anyone so
I
didn't then something
changed I met Grover we had a lot in
common
only and not just because we were both
at the bottom of the food
chain and you know what it felt good to
talk about these things with Grover I
can almost believe they were
imaginary weird but
harmless until the day that changed
too until the day one of them decided to
come for me
[Music]
morning